bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce numéro de
votre mensuel politique dédiée à
l'actualité politique du territoire nous
reviendrons tout à l'heure sur le
déplacement de bruno le maire à
versailles nous avons rencontré l'ancien
ministre député de leur candidat à la
primaire de la droite et du centre et
puis dans quelques instants nous
parlerons aussi avec nos invités du
mouvement et nuit debout à saint quentin
en yvelines alors que les manifestants
parisiens se sont réunis dans la journée
devant l'assemblée pendant que s'ouvrait
le débat parlementaire sur cette loi
travail très contesté pour le moment en
retour au sur les conséquences de la
guerre que se livrent au front national
marine le pen et son père jean marie le
pen malgré son exclusion ce dernier
souhaitait organiser son propre
rassemblement le 1er mai et plusieurs
cadres du front national l'ont soutenu
c'est le cas de philippe chevrier le
responsable départemental de la
formation dans les yvelines conséquence
le bureau politique national a décidé de
l'évincer
les précisions avec william l cette
fonction il occupait depuis huit ans les
du front national philippe chevrier
conseiller municipal à rambouillet
conseiller régional d'île de france a
été démis hier de son poste de
secrétaire départemental du parti
c'est en raison de sa participation à
manifester soir lundi à jean marie le
pen le pas mais il n'est pas possible
d'avoir des des fonctions de sodexo soit
d'encadrement front national en
participant à ce style au front national
une proximité avec jean marie le pen
dont l'élu ne s'est jamais caché depuis
son adhésion au parti
je rencontre comme vous l'avez dit
fortement
jean marie le pen évidemment beaucoup de
réticences et je vais poser des
questions franches sur l'antisémitisme
la xénophobie sur un tas de choses
suit alors ça va aussi et c est sa
réponse a été absolument de l'éclair
s'est montré clair et convaincant
donc du coup et en même temps bon il
répondait à mon souci concernant l'euro
est louée et le loup erding frontières
donc voilà j'ai j'ai adhéré tout à fait
normalement et puis progressivement j'ai
été responsable de circonscription du
côté d'hambourg y est et puis mais après
départemental philippe chevrier n'a pour
le moment pas encore donné de réponse
officielle à la presse concernant son
éviction mes comptes communiqués dans
les 48 heures quand on est impliqué dans
un mouvement politique les partis
politiques sur dd des rouages essentiels
de la démocratie française c'est quelque
chose de très important il faut observer
la discipline de ce parti et les
considérations personnelles d'amitié
éventuelle de qualité passe pas c'est
qu'après marie christine arnautu
vice-présidente du front national et
bruno gollnisch était aussi présent à la
manifestation du 1er mai et ont été
priés de quitter leurs fonctions
le très contesté projet loi travail
vanté par françois hollande arrive donc
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale sous la pression de la rue et
d'une partie de la majorité
depuis aujourd'hui les députés examinent
les propositions et pendant ce temps là
à contestation perdure à sacha vallès et
sa mine et sont deux participants au
mouvement nuit debout à saint quentin en
yvelines ils sont en place au bon soir à
tous les deux et bienvenue donc pour
nous expliquer un petit peu le les
raisons de votre colère et je voudrais
commencer par votre état d'esprit
peut-être vos revendications
n'aboutissent pas véritablement le texte
passe en ce moment à l'étude
il pourrait même passer être adopté
malgré une absence de majorité à
l'assemblée avec le fameux 49,3 cet
article permet de légiférer directement
comment vous ressentez vous aujourd'hui
les choses vous vous dites il faut
encore plus se battre ou finalement
abandonné faire du classement
en tant qu'étudiant tout ce qui va tout
ce qui arrive tout ce qu'on va arriver
on le fait de voir une loi qui va qui va
précariser les salariés ça fait ça fait
ça fait peur et ça donne envie de se
battre ça renforce la détermination bien
sûr et puis on a vu quand même que c'est
un autre mouvement jusqu'à présent il a
quand même eu un certain succès et c'est
une mobilisation qui paye
vous parliez du 49-3 à l'instant alors
il paraîtrait que peut-être donc
justement le fait que ce l'utilisation
de 149,3 soit vivement critiqué effet
peut-être venu un revenu le gouvernement
sur ce que le gouvernement soit revenu
sur cette décision nous ce serait déjà
un premier succès et et nous voilà elle
est contestée de partout c'est toi donc
le vrai pour profiter de votre présence
pour mieux comprendre nuit debout on
parle souvent du mouvement sur paris
avec aussi des débordements des
violences je le ferais réagir là-dessus
mais aujourd'hui qui composent nuit
debout et notamment à saint quentin en
yvelines vous êtes tous les deux
étudiants mais qui vient vous voir lors
de vos différentes réunions qui ont lieu
au pied de l'université a d'ailleurs à
50 ans alors le cd profil vraiment on a
on a de tout à nu debout on a des
retraités on a des étudiants on a des
élus locaux on ya vraiment grosse pas
une certaine un certain enfin il ya
vraiment beaucoup de monde qu'en fin nez
vous échangez vous faites des
propositions vous amener d'être des
idées autour de quoi tourner les
discussions juste un mot aussi rajouter
que mes deux bouts saint quentin en
yvelines c'est aussi à la verrière
désormais donc voila et puis justement
on a on échange
c'est ça qui est vraiment la richesse de
ce mouvement c'est que il essaye d'être
de faire intervenir le maximum de
personnes d'origines diverses et du coup
et bien chacun mais quelque chose de
constructif à porter sur différentes
différentes actions ou différentes idées
et on débat et on voit dans un contexte
dans un cadre démocratique et ouvert
vous avez participé au mouvement sur
paris et aujourd'hui lorsque vous
entendez le ministre des collectivités
territoriales c'est jean michel baylet
du prg parti radical de gauche qui
souhaite que ce mouvement notamment sur
paris s'arrête parce qu'il craint il
craint pardon un drame s'est justifié ou
pas c'est donc logiquement soient mieux
encadrés faut se demander quel de quel
drame il craint
est ce que c'est un débordement il ya
des violences alors est ce que c'est une
race ou une menace peut-être
personnellement je pense pas que
justement ce soit un drame c'est
peut-être un drame pour la manière dont
on fait la politique aujourd'hui
mais c'est un succès pour une nouvelle
manière de deux peut-être de s'exprimer
pour les citoyens mais sur les
débordements la partie des violences
imagine que vous la regrettée aussi
parce que ça donne forcément une
mauvaise image au mouvement et peut-être
c'est son frère c'est forcément
regrettable et des violences y en a il y
en a toujours eu dans les mouvements de
contestation ce qu'il faut savoir et la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est
qu'ils sont les personnes qui font ces
violences est ce que ce sont les gens
qui vont se déplacer à nu debout qui
vont vraiment aux ag qui vont essayer de
changer les choses qu'ils ont une
volonté de participer à des débats
démocratiques
moi je devrais intimement convaincu que
non je pense pas que si on veut qu'un
mouvement sont un minimum crédible on va
aller chercher on va chercher des
réponses dans l'avion sinon justement
pour être crédible s'il faut s'inscrire
dans la durée quel avenir pour nuit
debout il ya eu des rencontres sur paris
avec les syndicats est nu debout et dans
certaines villes de france aussi pour
parler de convergence des luttes il
faudrait se rassembler se structurer
aujourd'hui alors oui mais un ami debout
c'est un mouvement qui qui n'a pas un
seul but défini nuit debout déjà c'est
pas un mouvement qui soit commun partout
en france on peut regarder entre la nuit
debout de saint quentin et la nuit
debout de paris il peut y avoir des
divergences entre la nuit debout de
paris et par exemple la nuit debout de
nice il peut y avoir des divergences
j'ai entendu que à nice il y avait
peut-être une une idée de proposer des
des candidats à certaines élections
c'est pas du tout cas forcément dans les
autres dans les autres mis debout mais
oui l'idée c'est que nuit debout même si
même si on n'a pas de d'objectif précis
on essaye de voilà de chacun est maître
de notre de nos tient pour essayer de
faire avancer les choses vers quelque
chose de plus nouveau ou ne sont plus
représentés sur le fond aujourd'hui vous
vous êtes tous les deux étudiants quels
sont vos inquiétudes autour de ce texte
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète aujourd'hui
dans les différentes propositions alors
le texte on soit
moi ce qui m'inquiète aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils passent parce que ce serait
aujourd'hui le texte ne vaut plus rien
pour personne
il ya encore plein de plein de points
pour lesquels on est content mais on va
pas rentrer dans les détails ici c'est
important de ces propositions vous vous
êtes étudiant vous allez bientôt rentrer
sur le sur le marché du travail quand
vous entendez parler de surtaxation des
cdd par exemple vous vous dites ça ça va
peut-être dans le bon sens malgré tout
ça pourrait me permettre d'avoir un
emploi stable plus facilement bien sûr
ce qui ce qui est important c'est
essayer de limiter au maximum la
précarisation de l'emploi qu'on peut
qu'on peut observer aujourd'hui et
particulièrement du coup pour les jeunes
on sent concerné parce que justement
c'est une précarité qui touche beaucoup
les jeunes donc lui ce texte il est il
inquiétant parce qu'ils nous proposent
une précarisation en nous disant que que
l'on doit si on veut avoir de l'emploi
il faut qu'on soit précaire et c'est
ainsi en surtaxant les cdd c'est qu'on
veut permettre de faciliter la mise en
place des cdi forcer les entreprises à
maintenant je passe des cds qui serait
plutôt positif
oui alors c'est faut aussi se dire que
ce projet c'est pas si une volonté
commune
maintenant on l'a ce qui est derrière
nuit debout c'est pas juste le projet de
la loi travail la loi travail voilà
comme je le disais elle même même pour
le medef aujourd'hui elle ne vaut plus
rien elle ne vaut plus rien pour
personne cette fois travail elle a plus
de valeur effective pour personne ne
l'estiment aujourd'hui mais on est qu'on
continue à se mobiliser contre cette loi
travail parce que justement
et bien c'est un gouvernement qui
s'aperçoit que toute sa population est
contre un texte de loi et ben il faut
pas qu'il peut pas légitimement faire
passer ce texte de loi
et vous parlez du medef justement le
projet de loi travail qui arrive dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée dans sa
version actuelle nous fait être très
peur il ne créera pas d'emplois c'est ce
qu'a affirmé le président du medef
justement pierre gattaz vous n'êtes pas
donc les les seuls à critiquer ce cette
loi ce texte qui rentrant en débat
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée coûté le
représentant du medef dans les yvelines
c'est sur notre plateau il ya quelques
jours
ce projet a suscité beaucoup d'espoir et
il a été tordu remaniée sans cesse et on
ne retrouve plus du tout du tout les
outils nécessaires aux pme tpe qui était
qu'ils étaient les cibles
dans le premier projet pour retrouver la
compétitivité et l'âge liées au besoin
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on arrive à un
point de rupture savès et on arrive au
point de rupture
commandez 1-0 syndicales sont tellement
politisé tellement argue bouté sur des
des vieux principe qui ne font plus ce
qui ne marche plus je crois que ça c'est
un dialogue de sourds donc à quoi bon
continuer et nombreux sont des veaux
ahmad ezz qui savent pourquoi continuer
un dialogue on nous empêche de salariés
nous empêche de construire avec eux il
faudrait que tout passe par cgt force
ouvrière
donc pourquoi six années 40 un sens mais
pas partout viser le dernier point je
voulais c'était le laisser des taxes et
c'est une grande stupidité medef qui
n'est pas d'accord aussi avec les
propositions du texte vous n'êtes pas
forcément vous à d'accord entre vous
mais en tout cas vous contestez sur les
différents points
comment vous voyez la suite du mouvement
comment ça va se poursuivre par exemple
à saint quentin en yvelines
vous poursuivez encore paris il ya eu
pas mal d'intervention des gens qui
expliquait que le mouvement nu debout
pour l'instant c'était vraiment quelque
chose de relativement récent c'était
comparable à un bébé on est on peut
difficilement dire ce que va devenir ni
debout ce que ce que je trouve important
dans ce mouvement c'est que aujourd'hui
on a des gens qui commencent à réfléchir
des gens qui s'intéressent peut-être à
la politique qu'ils ont l'impression
qu'ils ont leur mot à dire
c'est ça qui m'a poussé à rentrer dans
nuit debout c'est à dire que moi j'avais
un avis et je n'avais pas forcément
envie de rentrer dans un syndicat ou
dans un parti pour donner aujourd'hui ça
m'a donné là ça m'a donné l'opportunité
de pouvoir m'exprimer devant des gens et
de me faire entendre et d'en débattre
il y aura des élections l'année
prochaine avec la présidentielle les
législatives ça vous donne envie d'y
participer de vous engager auprès d'une
formation politique peut-être ou d'en
créer une autre sa dépense donc
personnellement parce que voilà on
exprime bien personnellement et pas au
nom de nuit debout on n'est pas porte
parole personnellement moi c'est pas
c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse là mais
c'est vraiment justement de faire passer
un message fort à la responsable
politique de ce pays aux responsables
des grands partis de ce pays en disant
mon mât voiles à la manière dont vous
voulez nous représenter ne marche pas
les français aujourd'hui ne se sentent
pas représentés par les politiques de ce
pays
et justement leur fait passer un message
en leur demandant
de changer et du et dans ses
investissements dans son genre dans ce
changement
on parle beaucoup d'absentéisme
d'abstention pardon au moment du vote
des élections vous irez voter en 2017
c'est une question que je me pose
il ya une grosse crise de la
représentation aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression j'en croise de plus en plus
des gens qui qu'ils ont l'impression que
le système tel qu'il est si ça changera
rien
je pense que c'est pour ça que c'est les
bardes via des voies alternatives comme
nuit debout en tout cas qui vous a
motivé vous amène à vous exprimer
aujourd'hui merci à tous les deux donc
participants à nuit debout sur saint
quentin en yvelines et cette loi travail
qui est étudie actuellement à
l'assemblée nationale merci à vous nous
ouvrons à présent une page dédiée à la
primaire organisée par la droite et le
centre en vue de la présidentielle de
2017 justement le scrutin va se dérouler
en novembre pour cette primaire le dépôt
des parrainages a déjà débuté les
candidats occupent le terrain notamment
le terrain yvelinois bruno le maire
l'actuel député de l'eure était hier à
versailles je vous propose d'écouter cet
entretien réalisé juste avant que ne
débute son meeting présenté comme
l'outsider de cette primaire organisée
par la droite et le centre en vue de la
présidentielle de 2017 bruno le maire
est aujourd'hui troisième ou quatrième
derrière alain juppé nicolas sarkozy et
éventuellement selon les sondages
françois fillon le député et de leur
ancien ministre de l'agriculture mène
une campagne de terrain plus de 350 la
déplacement depuis à 2012 et en ce lundi
2 mai il est donc à versailles au palais
des congrès pour un meeting on va parler
tout d'abord gonsard bruno le maire dont
souffrent ses meetings qui va se
dérouler dans quelques minutes
avec toujours un style bien à vous en
chemise les manches surmonter ce sera
confiance parce qu'en plus il fait chaud
donc
voilà je tomberai la veste ça permet
d'avoir cette proximité et ce contact
direct avec les gens qui me paraît
essentiel dans une campagne électorale
campagne électorale c'est d'abord
écouter les gens libération vous a
consacré un portrait récemment il évoque
une décontraction à la barack obama une
façon de faire déjà vu aussi dans la
série house of cards c'est vos
inspirations barack obama et aux
sauvegardes house of cards suis pas sûr
que c'est une conception très cynique de
la politique même si la série était
excellente
en tout cas mettre un peu de naturel un
peu de simplicité dans une campagne
politique française je pense que ça peut
faire du bien
la vie politique française elle a besoin
de respirer d'avoir un peu de fraîcheur
avec toujours des déclarations plus ou
moins choc
juppé est un sursis je suis un sursaut
nicolas sarkozy avec lui on avait le
sentiment qu'on piétine et à l'entrée du
nouveau siècle ça il faut toujours cette
petite phrase choc contre vos
adversaires même si et si vous n'êtes
pas désigné candidat il faudra se
rallier avec eux derrière eux pour la
superbe dessus de toute façon celui qui
gagnera la primaire devrait avoir le
soutien de tous ceux qui ont participé
ça va de soi ça fait partie des règles
du jeu je pense aussi qu'à primaire
c'est le moment d'avoir un vrai débat
démocratique projet contre projet et de
bien expliquer quel est son projet et
comment il se différencie de celui des
autres concurrents à la primaire
n'ayons pas peur du débat d'idées je
pense qu'en démocratie le débat d'idées
la confrontation des idées
c'est salutaire une bonne chose on va
parler des idées mais toujours avec avec
quelques-unes de vos déclarations le
social a tué la solidarité on distribue
des allocations sans rien vérifier ou
encore à négocier c'est déjà renoncé à
appliquer le projet proposé aux français
aujourd'hui sur sur ces deux points vous
pensez tout d'abord que concrètement on
peut gouverner sans négocier en imposant
et puis sur l'aspect social aussi
permettre aux départements par exemple
de contrôler les comptes bancaires des
allocataires du rsa
ça c'est faisable je pense sur la
première question que ce qui est
essentiel c'est de tenir parole
vis-à-vis de ceux qui ont voté pour vous
vous avez de la majorité si demain je
suis élu le chef de l'état en mai 2017
j'ai des comptes à rendre à tous ceux
qui ont voté pour mon projet pour les
propositions que j'ai faites
car de deux choses l'une soit vous
ouvrez de grandes négociations avec les
syndicats nationaux qu'est-ce qui se
passera vous n'aboutirait à rien et vous
n'aurez pas respectez votre parole ça
fait 30 ans qu'on fait ça je pense que
maintenant il faut arrêter
il est temps de décider sur la base du
projet nous est proposé aux français ça
veut pas dire que je crois pas au
syndicalisme au contraire mais je crois
au syndicalisme de salariés au
syndicalisme politique je crois au
syndicalisme d'entreprise pas au
syndicalisme nationale ce que je veux
refonder c'est un vrai dialogue social
au niveau des entreprises où les
salariés pourront défendre leurs
intérêts avec leurs représentants
s'agissant des aides sociales moi
j'estime qu'il faut garantir que chaque
euro de contribuables est employé là on
en a besoin qu'il fallait vérifier les
comptes bancaires des différentes
propositions
elle est très simple département
distribuer des aides sociales notamment
le rsa
moi je propose que chaque banque donne
un certificat au département comme quoi
le bénéficiaire du rsa n'a pas d'autres
revenus que celui du rsa c'est
l'assurance pour le bénéficiaire du rsa
aussi
qui sera jamais stigmatisé moi j'en vois
jamais le modèle 6t jamais le mot
d'assistanat
je veux au contraire expliqué que quand
on donne de l'argent un bénéficiaire du
rsa c'est qu'il en a réellement besoin
c'est qu'il a besoin la solidarité
nationale mais pour pouvoir donner cette
garantie là il faut simplement s'assurer
de manière très transparente que les
allocataires du rsa n'a aucun autre
revenu complémentaire sur son compte en
banque
c'est pas le département c'est pas
l'état qui va contrôler ça c'est la
banque qui donnera le certificat je
reviens sur la première partie de ma
question si vous êtes élu en 2017 vous
gouverner par ordonnance
je gouvernerai les premiers mois par
ordonnance
pour donner un élan notre pays et
montrer que la politique peut encore
quelque chose
ce qu'aujourd'hui une majorité de
français se disent et des guignols les
politiques mais pas les causes
il dessine jamais il bouge pas les
choses et de nous font pas rentrer de
plain-pied dans le 21e siècle
ils sont pas capables d'adapter notre
modèle économique social politique aux
réalités que nous vivons nous si demain
je suis et du président de la république
je prendrai une série l'ordonance entre
le mois de juillet le mois de septembre
2010 est sûre la solidarité sur le
travail sur l'autorité de l'état
pour bien montrer qu'on entre dans une
nouvelle ère politique où les
responsables politiques assument leurs
responsabilités et prennent enfin des
décisions donc le renouveau en politique
pour 2017 c'est gouverner par ordonnance
comme le général de gaulle en 58 s'est
donné un élan au pays par ordonnance
il s'agit pas de gouverner pendant tout
le quinquennat par odense il est évident
qu'ils aient des sujets par exemple la
refonte notre système éducatif
la manière dont on revalorise la
carrière d'enseignante on repense sa
carrière des enseignants tout ça ne se
fera évidemment parole pas par
ordonnance tout ne se fera pas par
ordonnance mais il faut donner un élan d
des premiers mois pour que le pays
retrouve un peu d'air un mot sur votre
déplacement dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya ce meeting
dans quelques instants il ya aussi un
déplacement notamment au pôle de
recherche sur la mobilité du futur avait
des com est ici sur sur versailles quel
bilan vous faites de votre déplacement
dans le département
la dernière fois dans le département
vous était venu sur le salon de la
chasse à rambouillet un jour le son de
la chasse et la déplacement autour des
questions de mobilité
moi ça me confirme dans cette idée qu'on
peut retrouver un esprit de conquête
dans notre pays parce que j'ai vu à
satory en matière de mobilité du futur
les voitures qui circulent tout seul qui
ce guide tout seul avec un flux de
trafic est à la fois plus sûr moins
polluants et plus rapide c'est quelque
chose d'exceptionnel
nous n'avons pas à rougir notre
recherche en matière de mobilité
la google car dont tout le monde passait
très bien et je peux vous dire qu'il ya
des voitures françaises qui vont se
guider par elle-même et s'inscrire
elle-même dans le flux de circulation
dans quelques années qu'ils seront tout
aussi efficace et probablement moins
cher un dernier mot nous sommes à
versailles dans quelques instants votre
meeting est ici à versailles dans cette
salle quelques militants contre le
mariage pour tous vous les avez sans
doute peut-être déjà a déjà croisé vous
rappelle votre position vous l'avais dit
en 2017 si je suis élu ce n'est pas ma
priorité de revenir sur cette loi
vous allez les convaincre commence ce
soir là je suis pas sûr de les
convaincre en démocratie chacun est
libre de s'exprimer
du moment que c'est fait sereinement et
dans le respect des autres j'ai dit aux
militants de sens commun il ya
maintenant deux ans que je ne reviendrai
pas sur la loi sur le mariage pour tous
et que je ne défendrai pas le mariage
homosexuel
vous savez j'ai qu'une parole je pense
que quand on est chef de l'état une
faune avoir qu'une seule parole et tenir
ses promesses
donc vous n'avez pas peur d'être hué
tout à l'heure dans la salle quand on
est chef de l'état faut pas avoir peur
merci merci le maire et ses opposants au
mariage pour tous n'ont pas manqué de se
faire entendre lors du meeting de bruno
le maire une altercation a d'ailleurs eu
lieu entre l'un des militants
brandissant un drapeau et d un
sympathisant du candidat au coeur
notamment de la discorde des propos
qu'aurait tenus ce dernier à l'encontre
des partisans de l'abrogation de la loi
taubira
les discussions se sont poursuivies en
dehors de la salle et côté l'a jamais
dit ça vous monte il a juste dit que les
responsables politiques qui disait que
celle abroger les français sont partis
en qui le ferait pas était d'une galerie
noir et l'énorme différence vous du sens
des mots
serigne touba bien sûr n'augmenter vous
mentez il a juste dit que les réseaux
apolitique qui voulait qu'il promettait
l'abrogation comme nicolas sarkozy et
qui savait très bien qu'il ne ferait
jamais eux étaient des communes mais
derrière ça ne m'aurait jamais insulté
derrière ce terme
derrière ce terme en fait c'est toutes
les personnes qui souhaitent pour
l'abrogation de la loi taubira qui sont
aussi les risques d'une connerie noir a
toujours été là juste de normandie en
chirurgie qui est de toute façon alors
ils sont tous du monde ambiance
électrique lors de ce meeting de bruno
le maire bruno le maire qui pendant ce
temps a rappelé qu'il ne reviendrait pas
sur la loi devant ces 500 militants qui
étaient réunis pour l applaudir les
opposants au mariage pour tous veulent
en tout cas poursuivre ce combat
certains d'entre eux n'excluent pas
d'interpeller les autres candidats à la
présidentielle de 2017
la loi taubira est un noeud on est un
scandale vis-à-vis des enfants ça on
peut pas accepter la marchandisation et
adopté rouler et servaient membres des
représentants du bien sûr savez-vous
mais toute loi votée n'est pas une loi
juste et légitime au nom au nom de la
légion est majoré au nom de la légalité
vous savez ce qu'a fait hitler il avait
été élu légalement et ces lois étaient
légales donc si vous voulez c'est normal
que vous ayez y ait une réaction
épidermique de gens qui veulent soutenir
la famille et qui veulent soutenir les
enfants
autre sujet nous restons sur cette
primaire mais nous revenons dans un
climat un peu plus serein autres
candidats à la primaire à droite
françois fillon dans les yvelines ses
sympathisants se sont rassemblés ce
mardi matin pour lancer son comité de
soutien les plus récents sondages
créditant françois fillon d'environ 10%
d'intentions de vote 1 juppé reste
largement en tête écouter la responsable
du comité de soutien dans le département
suzanne blanc qui sait exactement où en
est notre pays notre pays dans l'europe
est notre pays
le monde et donc par conséquent il nous
paraît celui qui va pouvoir entamer des
réformes très vite parce que c'est ce
dont le pays a besoin
les réformes c'est pas 4 ans après c'est
pas cinq ans après c'est vraiment dès
que le président était lui qui plus est
maintenant nous sommes dans un
quinquennat quinquennat s'est vite
possible
et puis lui aussi est candidat frédéric
lefebvre il était à maurepas la semaine
dernière pour un débat public autour de
l'emploi le député les républicains de
la première circonscription des français
de l'étranger réclament un grenelle sur
cette question de l'emploi il fait
également partie de ceux qui militent
pour le fameux revenu de base avant de
refermer ce 7,8 politique un mot de
l'élection du nouveau responsable de lui
des jeunes dans notre département à 28
ans marc lerouge décroche ce poste
commercial de profession il est entré à
lui déniant 2013 il est actuellement élu
dans la majorité au développement
économique à l'emploi et au transport
aux clayes-sous-bois sa priorité être
plus présents sur le terrain et se faire
connaître auprès de la population
on va écouter parler les gens on va leur
poser des questions on va les écouter
et puis on va on va faire connaître nos
idées centristes et essayer de
s'enrichir aussi de toutes ces
rencontres qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de jeunes
qu'ils soient dans les yvelines ou
ailleurs qui se tournent vers le front
national
on a dans les yvelines la seule ville
front national des d'île de france
donc nous on veut passer un message un
message beaucoup plus positif un message
qui parle de république d'europe
d'espoir et pas du tout un message
mortifère com est aujourd'hui envoyées
par le fn un petit peu partout c'est la
fin de cette édition du 7 8 ce politique
je vous retrouve le mois prochain pour
un nouveau numéro merci de nous avoir
suivis